touchdown jackpot baby vegas touchdown
you know our guys work work way too hard
to to go through so dumb and dumber
that was the dumbest crap i've ever seen
i don't know what else to say you know
with seven seconds left i couldn't i
couldn't believe they all outed all that
blitzed us um
but as soon as i saw it man i was i was
thankful we just played the call that
the coaches called and
um you know we just got to execute but
you got to help us out at the same time
just being a you know better call at
that spot jets fans were kind of rooting
against their team because they really
want to see them have the worst record
get the number one pick and draft trevor
lawrence out of clemson which is kind of
bizarre
not really bizarre not in today's nfl
when fans have figured out that if
you're not going to make the playoffs
who cares and if it gets you in position
to get a franchise quarterback and your
franchise hasn't had one since joe
namath go for it don't celebrate the
victory celebrate the path to the guy
that will lead too many victories
if he are you are you surprised though
that like it's just like like hey the
hell was sam darnold i mean you know
don't they look at it and go wait we
were having these same thoughts a few
years ago and we thought sam darnold was
the savior maybe we just build a team
this time around and maybe we can win
with sam darnold i i don't know i just
i'm shocked at just the oh sam darnold
didn't bring us the playoffs it hasn't
been good we're gonna cut the cord get
the hell out of here trevor lawrence i
just i'm shocked by that a little bit
here's why you shouldn't be because sam
darnold is trying to get his footing at
a time when we see patrick holmes lamar
jackson kyler murray baker mayfield
i know but they have all-star offensive
don't have that's not i understand that
but you don't have five years to figure
it out anymore in the nfl and it's
easier to throw overboard a guy who
hasn't been able to show us anything
you know i think the seeing ghost moment
probably was when he got when he got
off of the idea that he's going to be a
franchise quarterback but
but regardless he's the quarterback for
now yep and maybe they'll keep him
around for next year under his under his
first round rookie contract that has a
you know a manageable salary for 2021.
they won't be keeping around greg
williams not that he was going to be
there anyway but
yesterday and there were a lot of people
we weren't the only ones that were
advocating that they should fire him
right now but after we finished the show
yesterday i went downstairs and i sat in
my office and i said you know i don't do
this very often but i'm going to write
something saying the jets need to fire
this guy right now because it was the
only play it's the only play if you want
to avoid going oh and 16 you have to get
greg williams out of there because
you've lost the defense yes quotes from
marcus may made it clear to me he's lost
the defense they're not going to listen
to this guy he's going to be a negative
presence even more negative than he's
already been for the rest of the year
he's not going to help you get to where
you want to be which is avoid owen 16.
and chris see here's the thing greg
williams doesn't care if the team goes
on 16 i had forgotten that he was the
defensive coordinator of the browns that
were oh and 16. i thought he came the
next year he was there for owen 16. it
doesn't attach to the defensive
coordinator it attaches to the head
coach
so
uh you know i i think gates may have
been tempted to say you're staying with
me you're suffering through this too but
it's not going to stick no to greg
williams so gase made the only move get
this guy out of here now if we wanted
any chance of turning this around
because the longer i keep this guy the
more the guys in the locker room who are
looking funny at him are going to look
funny at me thinking why in the hell are
you keeping this guy around after what
he did to take away our shot to avoid
the embarrassment of being on an 0-16
team yeah that that's it mike that's why
they can't keep him around
it he will cause total organizational
dysfunction he's going to ruin
everybody's thought of anything every
time they see him in the hallway in a
meeting room whatever it is and then
they're also going to wonder is this ego
going to get the best of them the next
time we're in a situation like this you
know again i don't know what it was i
don't even understand the rationale
thought of greg williams doing that i
really don't the only thing i can come
to is the fact that he just wanted to
stick it to john gruden and made it
personal that way i'm gonna hit your
quarterback and blitz you one more time
and embarrass your offensive system one
more time and if that's the case that's
a fireable offense that's just that's
holding yourself and your personal
vendettas and competition over
everything else you know and that's
what's crazy about coaches because you
know coaches of course will preach team
team team team team team team and then
you get a coach that's like that where
it's just yeah he's saying team team
team team but it's always i i i i and i
think players see that and he has a
reputation around the nfl as that
anyways so uh i think that's why they
had to get it done because if they do
want to get one win or maybe two or
something like that they just need to
get a guy that's going to leave a bad
taste in their all their mouse out of
the building
given greg williams history from the
involvement in the bounty programs now i
say that with full acknowledgement that
he was hardly the only coach definitely
or team that was
supplementing
with small cash prizes relative to the
regular salary that players receive
the application of clean legal hits that
potentially rendered their opponents
right incapacitated i i'm just
i'm not going to act like he's the only
one who was doing and that was one of
the problems with the way the nfl
handled the bounty scandal but greg
williams was as over the top cartoonish
as any coach in the past 20 years has
been the audio from the steve gleason
documentary sean pamphalon remember that
name from the pantheon of people who
just kind of popped up and then were
gone he had that audio of greg williams
the night before the saints 49ers epic
divisional game from the 2011 season
where williams is ranting and raving
about kill the head and the body will
die attack the head go after frank
gore's head go after this guy test this
guy
i i can't help but wonder
whether he set aside
the desire to win
and gave in to the desire to just take
one more shot at derrick yeah right
let's go get i don't like that punk
let's go get him let's send eight guys
after him we got one more shot at that
little so and so such and such profanity
deleted let's just go get him i can't
help but wonder whether or not that was
the motivation chris i i hear you mike i
don't think that's totally crazy i don't
i think it plays hand in hand with you
know the thought of john gruden too like
i said yesterday i think there's a
reason let's screw up their season let's
go right let's i'm not look i'm not
saying this is yeah but let's beat the
crap out of them one more time the
evidence is there from from everything
we know about greg williams the evidence
is there we're we're we're searching for
a rational explanation for why he would
do something so crazy and i was flooded
yesterday with this theory that it was
all part of a broader organizational
tanking play you're down 11 points yeah
they could have done before you're right
you didn't have to do it this way and if
you were competent enough to pull this
off you would have otherwise won a game
by now this was i believe
greg williams giving in to that
bloodlust that has characterized his
career he wanted to send his guys after
derek carr and maybe just maybe through
a clean legal hit
he would hey it's football derek carr oh
what a shame your quarterback can't play
next week and you lose and you don't
make it to the playoffs sorry john
gruden based on the history of greg
williams it's not ridiculous to think
that that's the explanation and that's
the only explanation that makes sense
for what we saw i i mean it's it it does
make sense you know i i don't ever want
to just blame anybody for trying to hurt
somebody or do anything but he's he's
shy i know how many times have we heard
from the last four years someone has
shown us who he is yes right this guy
has shown us for a decade who he is we
can't ignore it now no i i understand
that you're right and i i don't think
like we're far off i really don't i
because there's nothing really other
logical
to explain
to me other than like did he want to
stick it to adam gase and not let adam
gase have a one win i mean that that's
to me it's like one or the other
i don't know and i really
listen i watched you know some talk
shows and things yesterday just to think
like let me hear some people in the know
maybe somebody knows great maybe there's
a thought here nobody has a thought
there's nothing logical that makes sense
and of course
the way adam gase answered it after the
game and everything i mean obviously he
didn't think it made sense either
and i i you know i just i don't know to
me it's it's a it's a tough one i know
adam gase said too it's been talked
about or we practice it or whatever that
you know i don't i don't know if i buy
that either because i don't think adam
gase wants to make it look like some
coach went rogue on me and just called
whatever he wanted we'd never practice
that or done that that's not a good look
either he put everybody in a tough spot
it was ridiculous i understand it they
got four tough games coming up they're
trying to salvage from going for oh and
16. i mean they are and i just think
getting him out of the building is was
one of the best things they had to do if
they want to get that one win only thing
only they could do here's here's adam
gase from yesterday explaining the
decision to abruptly fire greg williams
with four games left
did you agree with his decision last
night on the blitz call at the end of
the game and how much factored into that
call factored into your decision
well i
obviously wasn't happy about that call
and
you know that
that was a
heartbreaking way for our guys to to
lose the game
you know
for
for that to happen in that situation
it's just
just
we can't have that happen
yeah look he had to do what he had to do
and
sheree williams and i were talking about
this last night on pftpm
one of the problems that you get into
when you are a coach
who became a head coach because you
developed an expertise in one side of
the ball and you hire a coordinator for
the other side of the ball and you give
him the keys
gase did it with williams mike zimmer
does it with his offensive coordinator
plenty of coaches do that where they
surrender they abdicate they don't
delicate delegate they abdicate
half of the game
to an assistant coach yeah when you do
that as gays did with greg williams
what can you really do in one of those
moments where you're thinking
what the hell is he doing now what can
you really do then once you have
surrendered that responsibility and
backed off and focused on your side of
the ball you know the sean mcvay sitting
on the gatorade cooler
mapping out right his plans for the next
drive on offense while wade phillips
runs the team
when you do that
you necessarily assume all risks
associated with it chris that the person
to whom you've delegated that side of
the ball is going to do something crazy
and when it's time for you to intervene
what are you going to do what are you
going to do and i think that's one of
the reasons why gase was was flat-footed
and handcuffed right what's he going to
do he's given the keys to greg williams
you're right it's a tough spot it is
it's the way that they design their you
know structure of power there and a lot
of teams do that it's not to say that's
wrong or anything like that uh but
you know i guess that's where you have
to go into you have to know the guy you
have to know the guy you got to make
sure you're really paying attention to
the call late in the football game to
make sure they did have one time out
left you know and sitting here as a
tuesday morning quarterback i mean yeah
could adam gase maybe heard that call
call a timeout and go like wait hold on
let's make sure we're all on the same
page here and talk about how we're gonna
defend us and do that you know that that
would be about the only avenue he would
have there because you're right other
than that it's really
it's a tough spot and uh he just went
rogue i don't know any other way to say
it it's it's totally inexplicable it's
ridiculous it's crazy from every asset
that corner matched up with henry ruggs
like you said he had like you said
yesterday and you're so right he had a
bite on the double move if henry rux
catches a slant he's going to score a
touchdown so
he's got to respect that too
so that just from all everything there's
no way to make logic out of it there's
not a match up or anything you can look
at to think oh okay i get it that makes
sense no it doesn't
no it absolutely doesn't none of it
makes sense and the only thing that
makes sense and again i i i don't make
this accusation lightly but the evidence
has been there for the past decade
that's who greg williams is that's who
you're hiring when you hire him and at
62 he's had a full career in the nfl if
anyone hires him now
it will be beyond incomprehensible you
know for the past few jobs i just
thought well hey
apparently this guy is one of the best
defensive tacticians we've ever seen
he's got it all figured out that's how
he keeps getting employed i thought he
was done frankly chris
when during the bounty scandal he
submitted an affidavit in which he said
that jonathan vilma former saints
linebacker originally drafted by the
jets by the way
that vilma had indeed offered ten
thousand dollars to anyone who
incapacitated brett favre in the 2009
nfc championship game i thought at that
moment he would never be accepted again
in a locker room and i don't know
whether players three or four years
removed from that just you know no one
really clued them into it they weren't
following one of those kinds of grants
was going on
career was over
yeah if you ever explained to a player
what this guy did then maybe they'd say
well what the hell i'm not playing for
this guy but it never it never really
had the occasion to percolate so i
thought he was done then i i clearly
think he's got to be it's i'm sorry i'm
sorry it's done it's done
and i i i don't call for someone to be
fired lightly either but those
circumstances and everything we know
about the guy it all came to a head and
uh the jets went ahead and did it and i
think they were going to do it
regardless of whether anyone outside the
building was saying that they should it
was the only thing they could do yeah i
i think so it was the only thing you
could do and you know what what done
it's a good question i mean
he has been a good defensive coach for a
long time i have a hard time thinking
that
you know he'll be hired as a defensive
coordinator somewhere i do because that
now when you have something like this
right even if there was a coach who was
going to be a head coach next year is
trying to line up his staff and do those
things you're not going to be able to
sell to the owner of the fan base greg
williams anymore so if there was any
thought of like hey he's going to join a
new coaching staff somewhere that's
going to be a hard sell i don't think
that happens and i think you're right i
think he's probably done as far as
defensive coordinator unless some
unforeseen circumstance has i think he
has to go somewhere and be a defensive
assistant you know assistant to the head
coach something like that and then maybe
if he got somewhere where the defensive
coordinator got fired during the season
then he would take over but i'd have a
hard time thinking he got hired you know
for a fresh new start in that position i
think his best bet at this point is to
wait for the next reconstitution of the
xfl which is coming in 2022.
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports